northern ireland's first minister was at
the center of attempts to restore
power-sharing government
when unfounded rumors of an extramarital
affair with a close protection officer
began circulating online lawyers for the
dup leader
argued that dr christian jessen who
presents the embarrassing bodies tv
program had libeled her by tweeting the
false allegation
and refusing to delete it her lawyer
paul tweed
says social media providers need to take
note of this case
social media have a massive
responsibility here they've been
claiming for years that they're not
publishers that they're really a
platform
which enables them to facilitate mr
jessen and others
in firing out these tweets you know just
at a whim
and when it went a system even though
the allegation was totally and
absolutely fabricated
mrs foster who's been married for 25
years
said it was very humiliating to see that
the relationship that's most important
to me
had been trashed if you like and put out
there in the public domain in that
fashion
the mother of three added it was very
distressing at the time
and yet i had to continue dealing with
matters of great importance
the court heard that dr jessen's tweet
referred to mrs foster
as the sanctity of marriage preaching
woman thought to be a reference to her
party's opposition to same-sex marriage
asked if she believed in the sanctity of
marriage she said yes
but strongly refuted any suggestion that
she's homophobic adding
i have many gay friends mrs foster whose
democratic unionist party held the
balance of power at westminster for two
years
recalled how she'd been forced to
discuss the unfounded rumor with her
children
two days before christmas judgment in
her defamation action
was reserved to a later date david
blevins
sky news in belfast